I was asked about money and saving and
investing and what the most important
things are start with the basics what do
you need for how long and what do you
have in relationship to that that's most
fundamental then you can get into the
more esoteric stuff the most important
principle is about what I call the Holy
Grail of investing in a nutshell I could
describe it as if you can get 10 or 15
good uncorrelated Investments you can
red reduce your risk by up to 80%
without reducing your return that means
you increase your return to risk ratio
by a factor of five risk reduction is
really key the only way you can deal
with this debt is to earn more than you
spend and we're going to have to change
our behaviors that requires a lot it
means you either have to work harder
more productively to earn more than you
spend or you're going to have to cut
your spending and that's just the way it
is the
clearest indicators of when a uh fiat
currency is going to decline
into uh you know collapse is when those
who are holding its debt sell the debt
and the government Central Bank has to
print money to buy that debt in large
size while that's going down